even in seemingly ridiculous news
stories you see the rot Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue do you get
that when I was a kid you know
occasionally if there was one lying
around maybe I would have taken a look
but not in a while have I ordered Sports
Illustrated I don't read Sports
Illustrated I don't think many people do
but they've made history this year
because for the first time they will
have a dude on the cover of their
swimsuit issue now it is a dude who
thinks that he's a woman or pretends to
be a woman who dresses like a woman but
it's a dude talk about a gender parity
you know talk about rising up over the
oppressive yoke of the established class
finally men who have been excluded from
the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Issue
for so long finally we get to overcome
that oppression from the women from the
matriarchy and wear bikinis on the cover
of the of the issue
this guy valentina Sampaio is is guard
to appear on this cup on the face it
seems like a stupid story
nobody cares no one even reads Sports
Illustrated but this a little story
carries a lot of significance the reason
that the left is pushing this trans
issue which affects what how many people
are genuinely confused about their sex
well more and more each day but as a
medical matter very few a vanishingly
small percentage of people but the left
has pushed this for years the bathrooms
the transgenderism in Hollywood Halle
Berry is now not allowed to play a woman
who thinks that she's a man
because women who think that their men
can only be played by men I guess that's
another win for the oppressed men over
the matriarchy the reason they're
pushing this is because at the heart of
that is a cherished leftist premise
which is that there's no difference
between men and women the sexes are not
complementary they don't go together
they're indistinguishable they're
identical men can be women women can be
men we're all just sort of the same
we're all just these floating atoms we
have no natural constraints by our
biology no natural social constraints by
say our family or our local communities
or our voluntary associations we
are all just free-floating atoms this is
why sometimes you'll see when there are
big debates between the most arch
libertarian the most arch communist they
both have the same premises which is
that people are just individuals that
can do whatever they want basically and
then one group says they should all be
separated all the time and one group
says they shall be brought together all
the time when they're all separated it's
much easier to bring them together which
is why the advance of hyper SuperDuper
individualism tends to lead to a growth
of the state now is all of that
contained within the Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Issue is all of our all of
these premises contained within a dude
wearing a bikini and the cover of the
magazine this radical liberation that we
can overcome it yes it is but we don't
notice it that's cultural hegemony
that's political correctness whatever
you want to call it that's how insidious
it is it's why we have to pay very close
attention to the small things on the
great television show that the crown the
Queen's private secretary Tommy
Lascelles has this great line which is
he's talking about why it matters that
we pay attention to our rituals to our
traditions he's talking about it in the
wake of the abdication of Edward the
eighth and and the line is it's in the
small things that the wrought starts do
the wrong thing once it's easier to do
it again do the individualistic thing
once it's easy to do it again that's
what we're seeing here that's why this
relentless push where the fa mask do
they do that just do it just to use the
effing pronoun call him/her just do it
it's nothing it doesn't matter it's not
important let men go change in the
little girl's room just do it it's not
important well if it's not important why
do you seem so intent left-wingers on
forcing us to do it if it doesn't matter
if it's just a small thing because it's
not just a small thing even small things
are not small things that is where the
rot begins
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description